une immense satisfaction c'est une
immense satisfaction pour la défense et
c'est surtout je crois un grand succès
pour la justice qui en fait revient à
dire que une enfant 15 ans ne peut pas
être placé en garde à vue et faire des
déclarations sans avoir des droits
fondamentaux qu'ils soient préservés
présence d'avocats droit au silence
présence d'un représentant légal
donc c'est une très grande satisfaction
je dois vous dire je viens d'avoir
muriel bolle au téléphone elle a hurlé
de joie tellement elle est heureuse et
soulagée
et justement ça allez vous demander quel
est qu'elle ait commencé sans votre
cliente aujourd'hui tellement heureuse
vous avez lu dans son livre vous avez
entendus dans ces déclarations récentes
qu'elle porte comme un fardeau
ces déclarations de 1984 qu'elle a
faites devant la gendarmerie dans les
conditions très particulières de
l'époque elle porte comme un fardeau la
mort de bernard laroche
donc aujourd'hui cette annulation est
pour elle un énorme soulagement
et elle m'a dit et confirmé que pour
elle c'est peut-être encore une
démonstration de l'absolue innocence de
bernard laroche
qu'est ce que cette décision prise par
le conseil constitutionnel va impliquer
derrière dans la procédure justement qui
est en cours alors c'est pas la fin de
la sphère grégory et c'est bien ce soit
pas la fin de l'affairé grégory il
absolument nécessaire indispensable
qu'on sache qui est le coupable ce
meurtre atroce une réelle bol la
première à souhaiter ça implique en
revanche que ces déclarations de 1984
dans lesquels elle s'auto incriminer et
elle indiqué qu'elle était avec bernard
laroche dans le véhicule et que l'enfant
avait été emporté
cette déclaration est annulé elle est
censé n'avoir jamais existé et donc plus
personne ne pourra invoquer cette
déclaration comme un élément à charge de
muriel bolle ou de bernard laroche
ça signifie que c'est la fin de la piste
muriel bolle